the dup is certainly a party in disarray
deeply divided by the brutal manner by
which arlene foster was
deposed as party leader at the end of
april they say be careful what you wish
for
edwin putz had aspirations of leadership
for many years
he co-led the coup against her but he
discovered when he got the new job that
it came with all the same old
challenges a party boxed in with no room
for compromise
because of the existing unionist anger
over the brexit border in the irish
sea so just 21 days into the job he's
been overtaken by events and forced to
resign
and that could have very serious
implications for the power sharing
government here
at stormont i've just heard in the last
few minutes that tomorrow's
north south ministerial council meeting
is unlikely to take place and that is
not a good sign
the dup were not happy that the british
government had
granted sinn fein's request to legislate
for irish language
rights at westminster if it didn't
happen here they told edwin putz not to
nominate paul given his first minister
but he went ahead and did that anyway so
you've now got to wonder how
tenable the new first minister's
position is if he resigns to
power sharing goes with him just one
other thing to wonder about tonight and
that is
who might become the new leader remember
edwin puts one by 19 votes
to 17 it was very close the other
contender
sir jeffrey donaldson the man who leads
the party at westminster
he was giving nothing away when he left
party headquarters this evening
but he's got to be the front runner to
be the third dup leader
in the space of two months